Talib who's with this today Thank You
mr. chairman and thank you so much for
allowing me to be here this is pretty
complex the more I hear about this and
as an attorney as well you know I'm
always constantly looking at specific
actions and words and some of the other
circumstantial evidence in regards to
whether or not and it's very intriguing
mr. shivers you talked about hate
incident versus hate crime and so forth
I believe that the government's
priorities and resource allocations
should be in coordinates with the
magnitude in nature of the violent
extremism threat in the United States do
you all agree with that
I with one caveat I would say risk is
how we evaluate evolution of resources
we we take into account threat
vulnerability and consequence do you all
agree and we go through a threat review
process both at headquarters in the
field to do that to make sure our
resources are properly properly aligned
against our threats and I just want you
to know many of my question next
questions I know that you don't get
didn't make these decisions but I'm
trying to educate the public but also
put in congressional records so mr.
McGarity the FBI has indicated that
approximately 20% of the FBI's pending
counterterrorism cases are characterized
as so-called domestic terrorism
investigations which roughly parallels
resource allocations of counterterrorism
special agents and field offices working
on domestic terrorism is that correct
yes how many pending domestic terrorism
cases does the FBI FBI have currently
approximately it again it's a point in
time ecstatic about proximately month
ago is approximately 850 that's the
number I have thank you and white
supremacist supremacists extremism cases
would you would all fall under so-called
domestic terrorism correct yes
my understanding is that the remaining
80% of FBI's pending counterterrorism
cases would be characterized as the
International what we call you called
him H I hate these labels by the way it
drives me as a Muslim like I just hate
them because it automatically makes me
feel like people are targeting those of
different faiths and colors and so forth
but call hve
cases so I think you're 80% left from
that budget the resources are going to
no no so we have approximately 4,500 to
5,000 terrorism cases okay of that
approximately 850 domestic terrorism
cases so take the rest those are
international terrorism cases okay so so
we have approximately a thousand
homegrown violent extremist cases and so
actually a thousand HZ Elios those folks
are falling under this this
international terrorism okay so one of
the things that came up is and it's a
good question to you mr. work here
anybody else that like to answer do you
think we should have a domestic
terrorism statute I will say as a former
prosecutor as a former investigator I
want every tool in the toolbox and I
want options so if I can have McGarity
so I would say I want another tool in
the toolbox yes but I'll defer to the
department justice of course to work
with Congress if there's a statues so
the tools we have is not enough
I mean if somebody's threatening to to
kill people based on their faith to kill
people based on their beliefs and or
just you know that kind of sort of you
know I loved how you said any vices
threat to society right any sort of form
of violence and I appreciate that but
there's not enough right now to give you
all power so I want to give you an
example so I've been in office for about
six months and when you get something
like this attention congresswoman
alexandria Ocasio Cortez and ragheads
Rashida to leave in Ohana Omar I was
totally excited and pleased when I heard
about 49 Muslims were killed and many
many more were wanted in New Zealand
this is a great start let's hope and
pray that it continues here in the in
the good old USA the only only the only
good Muslim is it is a dead one
how is that enough not enough to fall
under domestic terrorism if they're
targeting solely based on my faith and
others in saying that a good Muslim is a
dead one obviously directed to me by the
way they copy
in this threat to my office they copied
the US Department of Justice the
President Department of Homeland
Security and so forth and we get so many
of them and I keep asking what happens
what happens to these individuals are
they you know I want I'm being sincere
I'm not trying to I'm really sincere I'm
a mother so I want to go home to my two
boys so I'm first my empathy I'm in
charge of domestic terrorism
international terrorism
I don't differentiate either when the
threat comes in nor does the FBI we work
on both to say I appreciate that and I
hear that throughout your testimony is
very consistent mr. security but how
come we don't have enough tools right
now to pull these people in because this
is a former and you can see there's a
pattern well there's two parts of that
so I can tell you the FBI the Joint
Terrorism Task Force we are working hard
as we said earlier we are working hard
if there's another statute that you
think is needed come talk to the
Department of Justice absolutely I mean
I think they've said that during the
last testimony back in May those type
charges as you're explaining that I I
want to arrest that person before they
do something that's a have to right
right what am I gonna do I'm gonna look
at any charge I can do probably in that
case if it gets a little more specific
with the violence and targeted violence
I'm gonna use 18 USC 875 an interstate
communication threat that's what I'm
going to do so and we do that every day
and we actually do it more and I'm not
trying to be argumentative here either
I'm just telling you men and women the
FBI are out here working this threat
hard and we arrest more of our subjects
on domestic terrorism and we do
international terrorism and we're doing
it as we don't have enough resources I
think being spent on it and you know mr.
she was made a knight because I am four
and I want know my I want my colleagues
to know I go I have my coffee hours I
have people protein I absolutely welcome
freedom of speech I I welcome anybody
that has an opinion even about my faith
but to get to the point where they pass
it tour as a threatening life and and
really I mean to me that is enough
sometimes I you know the protected
speech and that's something we have to
be very careful and tread very carefully
very very carefully with that but
methought point where this person where
I feel like if it came from somebody of
different in no matter what as we try to
proceed we say that's not true but I
feel like if they were Muslim or black
that it would be handled differently
even the threat that we had in Florida
they released him on a tether I had to
go to Florida the same weekend I
couldn't believe they released him on a
tether and I've been on the other end
you know defending many people that were
wrongfully accused and wanting to I
couldn't get them on bail for the
smallest incident of you know attempted
assault and so forth right
serious offenses I believe but in many
ways they these kinds of incidents when
it comes to threats of life towards
other people based on you know somebody
of Jewish faith Muslim being black in
America this anti blackness movement
that we have when when do we take those
so seriously as as a movement that is
obviously pushing violence I mean when
do it went wind I mean at this point
you're letting the person out on a
tether I know you're not I know you're
not mr. mercury and like what scares me
about your you know kind of not
requesting but you're saying do you do
you think we should have domestic
terrorism statue what scares me about
that is that we're Savannah and I'm
sorry mr. chairman that we're going to
allow this big balloon of then we're
still gonna be leaving people out I feel
like if they're threatening the life of
someone else that alone should be just
enough for us to get them on it if it's
not based on and it's based on hate
because they're mentioning a faith if
it's based on color and so forth sexual
orientation that should be enough and I
mean I commend you all in trying to keep
our country safe but I feel like almost
like we need to be proceeding in a way
that we're spending enough resources and
money with the people that are here now
that are threatening lives of a fellow
Americans thank thank you mister Lee I
was so mesmerized by your statement I
lost track of time there so that was my
fault
come now to mr. Malinowski you I yield
to you for five minutes
thank you
mr. mr. chairman